في هذه الاثناء قال الجيش الاسرائيلي في
تغريده انه اسقط طائره مسيره عبرت من
لبنان الى الاراضي الاسرائيليه وانه
سيواصل العمل ضد اي انتهاك لسياده اسرائيل
حسب تعبيره كما نقلت اذاعه الجيش عن مصادر
امنيه اسرائيليه ان المسيرات التي اسقطها
الجيش تابعه لحزب الله
وكان نعيم قاسم نائب الامين العام لحزب
الله قال ان تهديد وتهويل قاده اسرائيل لن
ينفع وان توازن الردع قائم وحاضر واشار
قاسم في تغريده الى ان المجاهدين
الفلسطينيين في الميدان وان محور المقاومه
في يقظه وهزائم اسرائيل تتراكم وان
النصرات حسب تعبيره
هذا واكدت وزاره الخارجيه اللبنانيه عزمها
على تقديم شكوى الى مجلس الامن الدولي
احتجاجا على الاعتداء الاسرائيلي على جنوب
لبنان وحذرت الوزاره من ان هذا الاعتداء
يهدد الاستقرار وينتهك سياده لبنان ويحرق
القرار الاممي رقم
1701 بدوره اكد وزير الدفاع اللبناني
موريس سليم ان الجيش اللبنانيه جاهز
للتصدي لاي عدوان اسرائيلي وقال ان
التصعيد يشكل تهديدا للاستقرار مشيرا الى
حرص الجيش على التعاون مع قوات الامم
المتحده للحفاظ على الهدوء في جنوب البلاد